en el cargo y en un informe cuando pones
tu vida en riesgo por este país y no
porque es el país donde vive sino porque
es un país en el cual crees
yo creo en este país porque eeuu
mantiene la promesa de un lugar donde
todo el mundo puede pertenecer nosotros
sabemos que para muchos y durante mucho
tiempo de esa promesa ha sido denegadas
pero también sabemos que eeuu está en su
mejor momento cuando hacemos que ese
círculo de pertenencia sea más amplio
hace diez años yo me uní a las fuerzas
militares donde despedirme por quién era
yo no solamente era posible sino que era
una política ahora en 2020 y no es
ilegal en eeuu despedir a alguien por
quién es o por quién ama
el anillo de una boda que celebramos
aquí donde estoy parado en este momento
refleja como este país puede cambiar el
amor hace que mi matrimonio sea real
pero el coraje político lo hizo posible
incluyendo el de joe biden
quien estuvo por delante de este partido
cuando dijo que la equidad para el
matrimonio debería ser ley aún queda
mucho por hacer pero si tanto puede
cambiar entre el 2010 y el 2020 imaginen
lo que podría cambiar entre ahora y 2030
imaginen lo que podríamos lograr con
esta coalición que estamos construyendo
en esta temporada con progresistas
moderados independientes e incluso los
que yo llamo los futuros ex republicanos
defendiendo un eeuu donde todo el mundo
pertenezca
joe biden está en lo correcto este es un
contexto y una lucha por el alma de esta
nación y para mí esa pelea no es entre
los buenos y los malos
es una lucha para señalar lo que es
bueno en cada uno de nosotros depende de
nosotros ser a eeuu un lugar donde la fe
se trate de sanar y no de excluir
podemos convertirnos en un país que
respete la verdad de que las vidas
negras importan donde podamos mantener
los temas médicos y de ciencia
con los científicos y de doctores
donde nadie que trabaje a tiempo
completo pueda vivir en la pobreza yo
confío en joe y en cámara harris para
que nos lleven hacia ese futuro mejor
porque he visto de cerca su empatía y su
capacidad así como he visto a mis la
capacidad mis compatriotas para
incluirse a unos a otros y hacer lo
mejor por la promesa de eeuu cuando yo
nací la idea si de un candidato buscando
un cargo
era algo visible pero ahora yo hice la
campaña para ser presidente con mi
esposo ganando delegados hasta esta
misma convención ahora vengo a esta
convención apoyando con orgullo a joe
biden y camareros demócratas con quienes
estaba en competencia hace apenas unos
meses